everyone its microphone water flows and
in this video I'm gonna talk about
stacking balances and how you can use
them in your trading now before I begin
weave disclaimer this presentation is
for educational and informational
purposes only it should not be
considered a solicitation to buy or sell
a futures contract and making the type
of investment decision a future train
contains substantial risk is not for
every investor and investor could
potentially lose all in more than the
initial investment risk apples money
that can be lost without jeopardizing
once been an security life so only risk
Apple should be used for training only
those with sufficient risk Apple should
consider trading pasture for it's not
necessarily indicative of future results
now tools I use in this presentation are
the order flows trader software this is
my software you know somebody posted a
comment all your videos are sell your
software well you know the reason I post
these videos is so people that use my
software can learn how to take advantage
of market situations you know even if
you're not using my software if you're
using another version of order of a
footprint chart from someone else you
know hopefully you could get some
information by watching these videos but
you know really the whole purpose is is
to you know show people that use my
software how to take advantage of the
information that's on the chart so you
know if you don't like it you don't have
to watch my videos you don't have to
subscribe that's fine but really the
reason I do these is is so people can
get a better understanding of what
they're looking at in the markets so
this is yesterday in the crude oil
September crude I don't on the
one-minute chart now I'm gonna talk
about the dis some of the differences
between a one-minute chart and an
arranged base chart shortly but I dare
say that you know when you're looking at
a minute based chart I tend to find that
imbalances hold a bit more than they do
on a range based chart and this was
yesterday about eight thirty five in the
morning
you got this big imbalance here you know
it's how many levels it's like one two
three four five six seven eight nine
levels that's a big one
normally most people look for a minimum
of three now you know what you have is
an imbalance you know because you got
zero against 50 0 against 46 somebody
swept through the market there and you
know an imbalance is when you have more
aggressive buyers and sellers by ratio
of four-to-one or more aggressive
sellers than buyers by ratio 4 to 1 you
know you either got buying imbalances
you got selling imbalances knowing you
have stacked imbalances
when the imbalances appear stacked
neatly on top of each other now my
software will also draw a box around
imbalances that are not necessarily
stacked like here okay so you know here
you have multiple imbalances this is
unique to my software it'll draw someone
will probably copy it and we'll call it
the order flow imbalance Algol or some
like that but really all it is
is you know I got imbalance here and
balance here and balance there it's just
as important as a stacking balance and
you can see how the market has rallied
up up up up you get there how you got
divergence you start selling off you got
aggressive sellers coming in here in
multiple imbalances so you know you got
aggressive sellers here aggressive
sellers here aggressive sellers there
and it's just as important as if you
have a stacked imbalance why is because
you got aggressive sellers coming in and
you can see how the market we just offer
high aggressive sellers coming in and
then the market sells off but what I
want to talk about is a couple things so
you know if you're using my software you
can make some changes if you want let me
just pull up the indicator really quick
just to give you an idea of some of the
things you can think about now again I
know industry standard for imbalances is
usually ratio of four-to-one some people
I know use one thousand or ten to one
it's percentage when I say one thousand
it's not one thousand to one it's one
thousand percent which is ten to one but
if you go in here into the settings
imbalances here imbalance trigger you
can't really read what that says I don't
know if you could make it bigger in
percent here so if you want to make it a
ratio of ten to one four hundred is four
to one if you want to make it ten to one
you'd be 1000 now imbalance cluster size
is set to three that's you know three
imbalances one two three there so if you
want to change it to four if you only
want to look for for stacking balances
you change it to four okay and so on if
you want to change it to five four five
stagnant balances you can do that now
this one was very interesting because
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna draw some
lines here just to give an idea you know
people always say well I just the market
pull back to a specific level you know
you can see how it pulls back down here
and then rallies again you know more
aggressive buying coming in why is
because that's an area where you had a
some buyers earlier not does it always
hold no but is it gonna give you a
decent little risk country yeah why
because you can be looking to be buying
somewhere in the zone or maybe a tick
above it you know and your stop is just
gonna go right below here 68 is a 68
bucks so you know say you buy it
somewhere in here around 60 you know 60
805 260 810 that's good you know
obviously if you could buy it around
here at 68 bucks that'd be great if you
could have a stop here at 67 99 but
realistically you know try and buy it
somewhere in the zone or just on the
cusp of the zone and you use this as
your stop you know just on the other
side there and you know what's your
profit potential if you could buy it in
here around sixty eight ten to sixty 805
you know earlier you had rallied all the
way up to sixty 850 before you sold off
again so what happens well the market
comes back down into that 68 this is oh
nine so it's oay to come down to 68 oh
eight before we shoot back up again and
what do we shoot back up again up here
in new highs 68 75 and then right up
again off this high you got a stacked
selling imbalance in here you got
multiple imbalances as far as littered
with selling imbalances and the market
comes off again it comes back down to a
prominent part of control for some
support at market rallies back up where
does it rally back up to you know it
well he's back up to where you had that
previous resistance and then it sells
off again so you know that sit on a
minute face chart I mean you know that
this one you know it does work nicely
you know this stack buying and balancing
in the next bar you know it held and
rallied up and you got the multiple
imbalances in here and we sold off where
do we sell off to we sold off to that
area of support so you know if you're
getting short off this high you do know
you have some support coming in down
here you know you got some near-term
support but obviously this stacks on a
balance blue that support out of the
water this support is now becoming
resistance and you can see how it's
trading back up into that area you know
support becomes resistance and
resistance become support and where we
trade back down or trade back down to
the next support level down here
okay now the difference between a minute
based chart like I said you know minute
based charts and range based charts
which holds better personally again you
know I'm not saying this is as the rule
with minute pays charts I just find that
stacked imbalances tend to hold a bit
better now that doesn't mean they don't
work on on range based charts listen to
eight range chart this is just this
morning today you know you have this
swing low here you start rallying up and
you know a stacked imbalance next bar
pulls back right within that zone and
then rallies up again you know here
we're sort of I'll show you this is no
this is yesterday this is that a
thirty-five area here or rallying up I'm
sorry I cut my days confused here just
see how else some of these other
imbalances you know here's a stack saw a
balance we do pull back further through
it but you know what you got a resistant
point of control there probably a point
of control and you sell off any more
stacks on the bounces yeah you got some
stacks selling imbalances here did they
hold
yeah they held but again I'm not looking
to be taking stacks selling imbalances
right after you sell off from 68 bucks
down to 68 67 50 right after you sell
off 50 cents I prefer to take them you
know when you're coming off swing highs
rather than after you sell off 50 Cent's
or like you're just after your rally
here you just after you sell off I
prefer to take them like this one here
okay we rallied up up up up we get to
the swing high 68 45 I was like 68 40
stacks on balance multiple imbalances
next bar multiple imbalances and then
you sell off again that's why I talked
about taking things in context you know
yeah you guys stacked in balance here
this worked but you know we just rallied
from sixty seven ninety five all the way
up to sixty eight twenty okay well you
just gave up twenty cents alright you
for me I'm not trying to pick tops or
bottoms I'm just looking for areas where
the markets going to be turning it's
gonna give me bigger bigger potential in
the trade like here okay so imagine you
know from this low sixty seven 90 up to
here sixty eight forty that's 50 cents
that's great but your stack buying
imbalance at this point is coming in the
middle of that move I'm
yeah am i interested yeah yeah I you
know if I was long yeah being feeling
good because you know I got some added
insurance that there's there's more to
this more left to this move and then we
rally up another 20 cents then you get
up here to the swing high okay what's
happening well you got negative deltas
up here here here here all negative
Delta's stacks on imbalance right off
the high it's one tick off this high I'd
rather be taking a stack sellin and
balance up here than a buying imbalance
and then we sell-off from 6840 back down
to 67 90mm you know because this is in
the morning again this is Friday morning
you know we shoot up a little bit here
but again it's it's sort of you know as
the move you know our lows is much lower
and you're getting your stack buying and
balance after a move up you know the
selling a balance and again I'd prefer
it a little closer to the high and this
one I'm not too interested you know
these are not again it's in a move
already you know I'd probably have
looked for a reason to be short
somewhere higher than necessarily down
here but then you see which start you
know again take take trades in context
of the market don't just take the trade
because oh you know I got a stack by an
imbalance I got to get long or I got
stacks on a balance I gotta get short
you know look for you know when you're
looking at aggressive buying or
aggressive selling coming into the
market try to look for it at turning
points in the market I mean if you're in
a position and you got it or if there's
maybe a breaking out of a range it might
be also useful but again I don't look
for stacking balance to get into a trade
after we just had a decent move
basically that's that's my approach
again you know people say oh you don't
know you're talking about well you know
fine whatever you mean that's how I use
it
and again you know thanks for watching
this video don't learn more about this
software go to my website order flows
calm so again thanks for watching this
and have a great day everyone
bye-bye